simple is widely considered to be the
greatest CS go player of all time it
turns out that he might also be the
greatest skin influencer of all time you
see back in the fall of 2021 Nomad
knives which had never been particularly
popular suddenly exploded in price weird
right well that's what certain skin
aficionados thought until they noticed a
very expensive variation of it was being
used in tournaments by none other than
simple look at this November 680 RMB now
it's double the idea was simple if the
goat took a liking to a particular skin
it was gonna do pretty well despite
being popularized by Oni pixel it was
actually Jesus who conducted a deep dive
into this phenomenon and observed that
there was actually a ton of evidence to
support it oh would you look at that
they're simple and he's Nomad blue gym
now I just need simple to start using a
battle scarred clear polymer Glock with
a d ha sticker on it and uh I'm set for
life